Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Qué pasa después de la muerte?
¿Hay un paraíso donde descansar?
¿Un tormento eterno?
¿Un renacimiento?
¿O tal vez solo la nada?
Bueno, un emperador chino pensó
que independientemente de
lo que hubiera en el más allá,
más vale llevarse un ejército.
Lo sabemos porque en 1974,
unos agricultores que cavaban un
pozo cerca de un pequeño pueblo
tropezaron con uno de los más importantes
hallazgos en la historia arqueológica:
grandes cámaras subterráneas que
rodeaban la tumba de aquel emperador,
y que contenían más de 8000 soldados
de terracota de tamaño natural
listos para la batalla.
La historia del ejército subterráneo
empieza con Ying Zheng,
que llegó al poder como rey del
estado de Qin a los 13 años,
en el 246 antes de Cristo.
Ambicioso y despiadado,
se convertirá en Qin Shi Huandgi,
el primer emperador de China después
de unir sus 7 reinos en guerra.
Su reinado duró 36 años y vio
muchos logros históricos,
incluyendo un sistema universal
de pesas y medidas,
un solo alfabeto estandarizado
para toda China,
y una barrera defensiva
que más tarde llegó a conocerse
como la Gran Muralla.
Pero quizás Qin Shi Huandgi
dedicó tanto esfuerzo
a asegurar su legado histórico
porque estaba obsesionado
con su mortalidad.
Pasó sus últimos años empleando
desesperadamente a alquimistas
y llevando a cabo expediciones
en busca del elixir de la vida
que le ayudaría a
alcanzar la inmortalidad.
Ya en el primer año de su reinado,
empezó la construcción de una
enorme necrópolis subterránea
llena de monumentos, artefactos,
y un ejército que lo acompañara
en la otra vida,
donde continuaría su gobierno.
Este magnífico ejército sigue en pie
en formación de batalla precisa
y se divide en varias fosas.
Una contiene un cuerpo
principal de 6000 soldados,
donde cada uno pesa
varios cientos de kilos,
una segunda fosa cuenta con más de 130
carros de guerra y más de 600 caballos,
y la tercera alberga a los altos mandos.
Una cuarta fosa vacía sugiere
que el gran proyecto
no pudo ser terminado antes
de la muerte del emperador.
Además, las cámaras cercanas contienen
estatuas de músicos y acróbatas,
trabajadores y funcionarios del gobierno
y varios animales exóticos,
lo que indica que el emperador Qin
tenía más planes para el más allá
que simplemente librar guerras.
Todas las estatuillas están esculpidas
en terracota, o tierra cocida,
un tipo de arcilla
de color marrón rojizo.
Para construirlas, varios talleres y
aparentemente más de 720 000 trabajadores
fueron empleados por el emperador,
incluidos grupos de artesanos
que moldearon cada parte
del cuerpo por separado
para construir estatuas individuales
que correspondían
a los verdaderos guerreros
del ejército del emperador.
Están hechos de acuerdo a sus rangos
y cuentan con diferentes
armas y uniformes,
peinados y expresiones distintas
e incluso orejas únicas.
Originalmente, cada guerrero
fue pintado en colores brillantes,
pero su exposición al aire hizo
que la pintura se secara y cayera,
dejando al descubierto
la base de terracota.
Es por esta misma razón que otra cámara,
a menos de 2 kilómetros de distancia
no se ha excavado.
Esta es la tumba real de Qin Shi Huangdi,
que se dice que contiene palacios,
piedras preciosas y artefactos,
e incluso ríos de mercurio que fluyen
a través de montañas de bronce.
Pero hasta que no se encuentre una manera
de excavarla sin dañar
los tesoros que hay dentro,
la tumba permanecerá sellada.
El emperador Qin no era el único que
buscaba compañía para su destino final.
Las tumbas egipcias antiguas
contienen réplicas de arcilla
que representan la otra vida ideal.
Los muertos de la era Kofun
en Japón fueron enterrados
con esculturas de caballos y casas,
y las tumbas de la isla de Jaina,
frente a la costa de México,
están llenas de
estatuillas de cerámica.
Afortunadamente, tan
despiadado como era,
el emperador Qin eligió tener sirvientes
y soldados construidos para este fin,
en lugar de sacrificar a los vivos
para que le acompañaran,
como las prácticas que había en
Egipto, África occidental, Anatolia,
partes de América del Norte
e incluso en China durante las
dinastías anteriores de Shang y Zhou.
Y hoy, la gente viaja desde todo el mundo
para ver a estos estoicos soldados
que esperan en silencio sus órdenes
de batalla en los siglos venideros.